- So did you ever actually get to meet him
after you did this?
- Who?
- John Cena
- Oh no, of course not.
Not yet.
I hope I meet him one day.
- Well that's a bummer I mean
I think he posted.
Didn't he post about it as well?
When he found out?
= I don't know if he post for himself
but his page he post a
picture of me on there.
He doesn't say anything.
He doesn't caption.
He doesn't tag me.
Nothing.
- He's, because you can't see him.
(laughter)
(clapping)
- I love him.
I don't know, Man.
I don't know what will happen.
Because if I see him I'm gonna freak out.
- You're gonna die?
- I love him.
I love him a lot.
- All right, well it's the first season
he's not here, small budget, but
I'm just saying, but see he's watching.
And he's gonna love this moment
and I want you to perform that song.
Will you?
- Oh yeah!
- Okay let's perform.
(cheering)
- You come on over here.
(music starts)
(cheering)
Unajifanya hunioni labda mimi John Cena
Ulinifanya mfungwa wako labda mi ni Madiba
Sina plan, sina cash, hata pesa mi sina
Eeh ndo maana unanitreati kama nimekuibia
Lakini mimi nimekupenda though
I don't know why you
treat me like a criminal
We were just together though
On the same line,
why you pressing enter though?
Some wanna act rough like John Cena
Some wanna get buff like John Cena
We used to be cool,
when I used to come through
Now you wanna act tough like John Cena
Chi! Chi! Chi! Chi
Chi! Chi! Chi!
Chi! Chi! Chi
Some wanna act rough like John Cena
Some wanna get ahhh!
What do you mean?
You said he's not here!
- Oh my god!
(cheering)
- You said he's not here!
(clapping)
(excited screaming)
- Holy cow!
- Nice to meet you.
- What?
- Very nice to meet you.
- We'll be right back!
(cheering)